you know
but at the end
but no i'm not i'm fine but i get it i
get it too because i'll see
like one of andy's exes text him right
and she'll like text him like
pictures of them why i don't know
but i hope she hears this
[Laughter]
i'm like please stop i it's really like
yeah and i don't think that they have a
relationship like that i don't think
they have like a i don't think she's
trying to
get in with him or anything like that i
really don't
but
it is like one of those things where i'm
like this is not appropriate you know
what i mean yeah and unless you guys are
friends like
are you really jealous i don't know her
you're not jealous of me and she'll
she'll dm me sometimes but i don't know
her that's also like a kind of um it's
better
that's a new tactic he does he follows
all of my exes and i don't like it yeah
it's like a weird jealousy thing yeah
sometimes but also wanting to show that
here like i'm cool with it but i'm cool
with it yeah and maybe it's genuine
maybe you know maybe i'm like jumping to
i'm maybe i'm thinking the worst of the
situation but it is one of those things
where i'm like ew
you know and i don't want to bring it up
because i don't want to look insane yeah
i don't want to look like somebody who's
like
crazy yeah but it it's like ugh
yeah that is
i have a message then yeah i don't know
her name but
as far as i see it right
you're a rising star
and i can see why she's jealous
i don't look at me right now you're a
rising star bobby let's stop right now
let me just say i'm being bullied i'm
being i'm not being bullied i'm giving
you a couple
i'll give you it's bullying with
compliments
no i'm not bullying you right let me
just look at me and accept it okay okay
so um look at me right now all right
you right
just look right this is my passport
photo this person making
oh oh oh oh oh
volcano no it's not it's a rocket okay
right
they're not good
you're rocking you know what she is
she's just
the thousands of other people
right it's very small and she's like no
it's not shut the [ __ ] up
all right you know who
you know who's in the rocket little andy
with his crooked spine right
yeah yeah and she's like what about me
all right and you're it's you can't even
hear her
because you're in a [ __ ] rocket yeah
baby you know what i mean yeah so i
don't know her name but look at me if
you're listening right now right
stop what you're doing because it's sad
and he's never going to leave
okay
they both won the lottery with each
other you heard about the dancing story
at the wedding yeah the outdoor dancing
giggling it up you didn't have a
relationship like that with andy
you were a glum lot like they say in the
in the book what is it a glum lot
in the a oh my god yeah yeah oh my god
and you don't have it
so go find some other guy
i mean yeah that does delivery i don't
know i mean i'm sure
a delivery is a good job good job
i think i think i don't wish this person
any ill i really don't but i'm like i
don't want you to die just [ __ ] off a
little bit yeah [ __ ] off
yeah
yeah [ __ ] under the door but don't die
it's like yeah yeah yeah take a nap yeah
you know
so you were telling me earlier um
but that's a message to you
little
the funny thing is my husband's like six
foot two yeah he's like this huge
towering man that i just dominate but
he's but also i have to say
and i was never gonna say this because i
don't like giving that many compliments
but what do you mean no i that's that's
just a sound i make
[Laughter]
so i want to say um
that a lot of times when you see two
comedians
together there's always like one person
that's just not as good mm-hmm right
yeah and
luckily in our lives we have a couple
i'll give you an example
we have tom and christina
they're both to me
at that same level and i have to say
that you and andy
are on the same level because even way
before
you mean you guys you did your stupid
[ __ ] white dance at the [ __ ] yeah
like happy white yeah